happy new year everybody it's the first
week of 2013 and you know what that
means all the video games that
publishers really didn't want to put out
during Christmas there are video games
coming out this year I swear it's just
getting off to a slow start but this
week on game like we've got two games
that are already out in Japan and that
are kicking off 2013 for American gamers
Anarchy Reigns from Sega is the kind of
game we used to have a lot of and it
doesn't really get made anymore a
multiplayer fighting game set in a big
3d arena in this stylish madcap online
fighting game for xbox 360 and
playstation 3 up to 16 players can get
into the ring and beat the living snot
out of each other anarchy reigns is the
latest effort from platinum games makers
of such exquisitely violent action games
as mad world and bayonetta and wouldn't
you know it two of the fighters you can
play as in Anarchy Reigns are the main
characters from both of those games if
you're a huge platinum fan for whom
money is no object you might have
already played this Anarchy Reigns was
released in japan this summer and the
games were region free and entirely in
English but if you waited you can get
the US version for just 30 bucks this
week reviews coming out of Japan were
mixed if you really love the concept and
the developer this might be your new
favorite game but Anarchy Reigns is
clearly not for everyone another unique
Japanese import available now on the
Nintendo eShop download store is
Unchained blades for the 3ds again this
is a decidedly niche genre it's a
first-person dungeon crawling
role-playing game unchained blades has
been dressed up with an interesting
anime twist 14 popular Japanese
cartoonists each contributed a single
character design to the game and the
gameplay was designed by people who
worked on legendary japanese
role-playing games like Lennar grandia
and final fantasy but all of this star
power doesn't seem to have equaled a
masterpiece when a version of unchained
blades was released last year for PSP it
only got a metacritic score of about six
you won so it's probably good for
die-hard role-playing dungeon crawling
genre fans but not the average player ok
yes 2013 might be off to a bit of a slow
start but this year is going to be
incredible for gaming keep an eye on
game life every week to find out what's
hot we'll see you next time